you want to know why sports are
America's pastime yeah take a look at
last night's football game for the
national championship the Clemson Tigers
with both national champion after a
stunning upset win over Alabama
punctuation clemson dethrones and
avenges players and fans celebrated last
night dramatic finish the last second
play capped one of the greatest title
games in college football history
that's right final score clemson beat
the defending champion Crimson Tide 35
to 31 the wind earned Clemson its first
national championship in 35 years Josh
Elliot of our streaming network cbsn is
here with a comeback for the ages Josh
you love sports do good morning I do
Nora I watched it I still can't believe
it for Clemson it was something more
than revenge for Alabama
it would have been historic validation
and for all of us most college football
fans across the country it was the
rarest of games one that exceeded all
expectations Watson touchdown it took 59
minutes and 59 seconds for Clemson to
topple a dynasty one
second remaining stealing a title from
Alabama in the game's final moment when
a man makes another enormous play but
early on the Alabama Crimson Tide was
rolling Scarborough breaks free post
Scarborough in the clear and in the end
zone again the defending champs jumped
to an early lead
punishing Clemson quarterback deshaun
Watson Watson escapes ex a huge hit and
the tide seemed destined to win
silencing Tiger fans with a touchdown in
the final minute Evercore scores but on
its last drive clemson proved too much
for the Alabama defense tracks by down
inside the TAT afterward watson who
carried the Tigers to victory was at a
loss for words this is bigger than
bigger than just me so this is just
impact some of the people across the
world
Thomas's father brother sir with the win
Clemson head coach Dabo Swinney denied
his Alabama counterpart Nick Savin a
shot at a record-tying six tighten it
since Rob one
I mean you can't make it up man I told
him tonight I told him that the
difference in the game was going to be
love it's been my word my word all years
been loving I said tonight we're going
to win it because we love each other and
for that man
Clemson head coach Dabo Swinney this
victory was actually personal
vindication he won a title as a player
at Alabama in the 1990s later coached
the program before he was let go and I
just want to let everybody know
especially employers all across this
nation a lot of your employees sluggish
leads and it was worth every single or
if you're like Aaron you're wearing a
Clemson Jersey in the studio today I
can't help but feel people happy for
these people to see such joy and this
elysian stand up Aaron so we can see it
unless you're in Alabama he is a Clemson
graduate a proud Plimpton right and
again you know games like this very
rarely are better than you might have
hoped yeah this one have you seen a
better college football game not maybe
the Auburn game no not lately obviously
try to find with this much on the line
we will be talking about this for a very
long time but right now we're moving on
Thank You Josh settle them down
Triumph's